Aren't you excited to play with Dirk?
He's the greatest
The greatest
You're going to love it here
Greatest city in the world
We're definitely going to the tournament this year
I can’t wait to share the court with you and
the legendary Ser Dirk.
Would you like to see him?
Is he...uh...
you know...is he like, uh...
His, uh, spirit is strong,
but I am afraid there is not much time left.
OK
He’s down to 10 minutes a battle
Oh my
But come, you will make him very happy
Ser Dirk, remember:
You can fight for this house for as long as you like
Danke, but I don’t have much time left...
maybe only...six seasons or something
Six?!
That’s fine...that’s totally fine
Is, uh, now a good time? Ser Kristaps is here to see—
Oh yes, yes!
Dirk, someone special wants to see you
Hello, my Euro father
You shaved your beard, Tyson
-Oh, that’s not Tyson, Dirk. It’s Kristaps!
-It is not him
Oh! Kristaps?
You’re...you’re on House Mavericks?
I am, yeah
Lord Mark, this is...truly a wonderful gift
Oh, it’s nothing
Almost makes up for...
the time I took a giant pay cut...
OK
to stay with House Mavs...
OK, we don't need to rehash the whole—
and you used the gold on...
Chandler Parsons.
Alright, OK
Not good
OK, well, I will let you boys alone to talk about
whatever European things you guys wanna talk about
like wine and bread and cheese.
I get it. All right. Later, dudes!
Mark is actually...
He’s a very cool guy
Your grace, I want to learn everything you have to teach me
Let me bask in the light of your wisdom
I will tell you what is the most important
Yes. Please.
Loyalty
For 56 years, I have worn only House Mavericks colors,
even as those colors went through
a questionable rebrand.
And though I showed my opponents no mercy,
I made no enemies because I betrayed no house
Tell me,
why did you abandon your house? Your fanlings?
Well...I was on House Knicks, and—
Oh, oh—say no more
OK, yikes, yikes. Never mind.
Kristaps, do you then swear
your loyalty to House Mavericks?
Yes, I do
Well then,
in the name of Dirk Nowitzki of House Mavericks,
I hereby declare you the next Dirk
OK, wait. Hold on
With all due respect, you said
I was the next Dirk, like like a moon ago
Oh...that’s right. OK, yeah.
Kristaps, you will be the next Dirk,
UNTIL Luka comes of age.
Right...but I’m already the go-to knight, right?
I’m scoring roughly 20 points a battle
What if, uh, maybe both of you are the next Dirk?
We’ll do double Dirks
Yeah, you can be double Dirks
Want to be triple Dirks? Could we do triple Dirks?
Triple Dirks? Who is the other—
I think I also told Maxi Kleber that he’s the next me
Ser, our next battle starts in eight hours
We need to start your stretches
Oh, dank—thank you, J.J.
I’ll be right there
All right, boys
Time to play some basketball!
What the hell, Kuz?
Oh, c’mon,
probably would have been more off target if I left you alone.
That arrow cost 200 gold
Who pays 200 gold for—
Ah, right
Wait, weren't you cutting ties with them?
Yeah, but I got to get that arrow back
It's going to be a collector's item
Oh, you must come to my barbershop
But I have a barber. He’s an eyebrow specialist
Hey Lonzo, I’m not sure it’s safe to climb in ZO2 boots!
If Lord Walton sees you,
he’ll give Rondo ALL your minutes.
Shhh! Shut up!
I want nothing more than to be by your side
Oh, think of the fast breaks
I yearn to toss your lobs
Think of the spacing!
Would you let me play power forward?
Yes, anything.
Even though I’m clearly a center?
Oh, whatever you want. Because together,
we will bring back Showtime.
Ugh, too bad Lord Demps would never trade me here
He just hates House Lakers
He’s always been jealous of big markets
Let Rich handle Dell
But you’d have to give up
your entire young core for my rights.
I would trade every single one of them
for just a chance to play with you.
Between you and me,
they’re a bunch of fools and overhyped squires.
Even the Ball boy?
Pfft. Lonzo?
Good riddance to him AND his oaf of a father
And once he’s gone,
we'll bring in a real Lord Commander
like Jason Kidd
-Wait! Stop! Stop!
-or Mark Jack—son of a—
Are you completely mad?
He saw us. He saw us tampering.
It’s all right. It’s all right. I know.
What should we do with you?
D-d-don’t trade me
I’m really good except for shooting free throws
and three-pointers
and layups,
but, uh...I was the No. 2 pick!
He was the No. 2 pick
The things I do for rings
Ow, ow!
-Ow, my ankle!
-My small Kevin Durant-like frame!
Oh, my bones have shattered like sugar straws!
Oh, come on, guys, shake it off!
You’re fine!
Just a little, uh...playoff push
from the greatest knight in the Realm.
Is someone going to help us up?
Well, I suppose there's always next year
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Right.
Sometimes, I like to pretend
that I'm subscribed to Bleacher Report on Youtube.
I get all the notifications,
and I can show my support for Game of Zones.
But alas, I'm back in Chai'Nos now,
and I don't get Youtube here.
But I do wonder,
will they ever do an episode about the Guangdong Southern Tigers?
I certainly hope so